we choose to go to the moon in this  decade and do the other things not  because they are easy but because they  are hard  because that goal  will serve to organize and measure the  best  of our energies and skills because that  challenge is one that we're willing to  accept  one we are unwilling to postpone  and one we intend to win and the others  too  many years ago the great british  explorer george mallory  who was to die  on mount everest was asked why did he  want to climb it  he said because it is there  well space is there  and we're going to climb it  and the moon and the planets are there  and new hopes for knowledge and peace  are there  and therefore as we set sail  we ask god's blessing  on the most hazardous and dangerous  and greatest adventure  on which man has ever embarked  thank you  [Applause]